oh [ __ ] it's not another shipping
container request if you're not careful
you could easily get sucked into the
shipping container cult this is where
they're going to tell you that a
shipping container is the best and
cheapest way you can build and own your
own home they're going to tell you all
you need to go do is find yourself a
piece of
shipping container for dirt cheap cut
some holes in it stack it together like
lego and whiz bang you have yourself a
beautiful home but what they don't tell
you is all the little things that make
an actual home liveable in today's video
we're going to be talking about why i
personally hate shipping container homes
as a registered architect here in
western australia and if you think i'm
wrong please try and change my mind in
the comments down below i'm gonna be
breaking down my top five reasons why i
don't believe shipping container homes
are livable before you comment david you
don't even know make sure you stick
around to the end of this video where i
break down the costings of a shipping
container home so let's get started with
number one shipping container homes are
traditionally used on large blocks of
land which means you have plenty of
space to actually build a nice quality
home but instead most shipping container
homes are designed around japanese micro
apartments which means they're so small
so constricted and they're really not
designed for the land use that they're
going on so straight away we have these
huge juxtaposition in the land and the
architecture a typical shipping
container home is either a 20 foot or a
40-foot shipping container now because
i'm in australia we use the metric
system which means a 20-foot shipping
container is 5.9 meters long by 2.3
meters wide by
2.393 meters high this dimension is
critical and i'll get to it in a second
the 40-foot chipping container is 12
meters long by 2.3 meters wide by again
2.393 meters high these dimensions are
internal so they are slightly bigger on
the outside like i mentioned before the
2.393 meter internal ceiling height is
critical so straight away this is not
considered a habitable space under the
australian design guidelines here in
australia we recommend any habitable
space has a minimum ceiling height of
2.4 meters so we're talking about your
living areas and your bedroom areas that
are considered habitable
non-habitable spaces are considered 2.1
as an absolute minimum so we're talking
things like storerooms toilets anything
where you just kind of pop in and pop
out relatively quickly so straight away
2.393
makes it below the minimum 2.4 standards
keep listening because this ceiling
height is actually going to drop
significantly more when we break down
the livability of this tin shed now just
like a tin shed a shipping container has
absolutely no insulation to it which
means it is going to bear the full brunt
of all of the weather factors outside we
want to make it a little bit livable a
little bit nice so what we need to do is
insulate this whole shipping container
if we start with the ceiling again we're
going to be talking about some serious
ceiling insulation which is probably
going to be about 210 millimeters deep
before we get anything actually working
so straight away we've lost another 210
millimeters and then if we want to run
any services like our electrical and a
mechanical we really want to stay clear
of this insulation as well which means
we want another 300 odd millimeters of
nice free-flowing space to be able to
actually get our services through
especially if we're thinking about
ducting so now we've just lost another
510 millimeters off our already tiny
tiny ceiling space so from
2.393 we've dropped significantly
including our suspended ceiling and all
of our services our ceiling level is now
1.893
meters clear this is before we put a
floor in which is obviously critical so
let's say we want a nice timber
laminated floor maybe we want some tiles
i don't know we can go anywhere from 20
to 50 millimeters which means all of a
sudden now we're at 1.85 meters
if i stand up inside this shipping
container my hair is going to clip the
top of that shipping container walking
around anywhere
i don't know about you guys but that
doesn't feel livable to me in any way
shape or form now the height is a
serious problem straight away i wouldn't
like to live in something this
claustrophobic but now we can talk about
the actual width of this ship container
2.3 meters wide is a very small narrow
room yes it's very long so that kind of
compensates for it but again we have no
insulation in our walls so if we go very
bare bones minimal in our war systems we
need at least 90 millimeters of actual
insulation plus another 10 millimeters
of plasterboard so we've lost 100
millimeters on both sides of our wall
now our internal width has gone from 2.3
to 2.1 so we're standing inside of 2.1
wide by 1.8 meter high tiny little cube
i'll give it the benefit of the doubt
and let's say we can insulate everything
underneath somehow magically and
therefore we're not crushing that
ceiling space anymore so we'll leave
these measurements of the inside as they
stand now and move on let's say now we
want to throw a beautiful king bed into
our fancy shipping container well the
king bed is 2.16
long so if you want to orientate the
king bed in the most logical position on
the shorter side of that actual shipping
container you can't you're not going to
be able to fit a king bed so that means
you have to orientate it the opposite
way and only have 8.5 centimeters either
side of your bed which means you can't
walk past the side of your bed to get in
you have to climb in from the back of
the bed every single time
this isn't a very good use of space and
if you have any sort of disability
requirement or anything that requires a
little bit of mobility you're going to
struggle to even move inside of the
shipping container now yes i understand
you can bolt on a million shipping
containers to each other make these huge
make them expansive and do whatever you
want with them but at the same time the
logic is the same regardless of how you
do it on today's video we're literally
just talking about the one single
shipping container unit rather than
bolting on a series of them to make
something a little bit more grand and
luxurious inside this one shipping
container unit you're gonna need a
kitchen and you're gonna need some sort
of bench typical bench 600 mil 900 for
the island we don't have that much room
so let's say we're gonna back two
benches together on either side of the
wall we lose 1.2 meters we lose another
100 mil for the handles on both sides so
all of a sudden we only have 800
millimeters or 80 centimeters to walk
down the middle between our two island
benches again we're on this large
beautiful property with a tiny micro
apartment design in a shipping container
it just doesn't make logical sense
in a kitchen you want a nice clean space
some reasonable distance between you so
you can actually walk from bench to
bench move pots and pans around
in this shipping container you can't do
that it is very tight and claustrophobic
at the moment but i guess what's more
important is people buy a shipping
container to think it is going to save
them lots and lots of money
now this is where it gets a bit
technical so stay with me i'm going to
try and break this down as easy as i can
the cheapest easiest home you can build
here in western australia cost you about
980 dollars per square meter finished
that means absolutely everything is done
for you except maybe carpets and
curtains so you have everything walk in
ready to go now because we live in a
crazy world all of these prices are
immediately outdated so take them with a
grain of salt they're most likely no
longer relevant by the time you watch
this video if we take our shipping
container 40 foot it is approximately
27.6 square meters which means we could
go and build a similar house for 27 000
that number is critical and it's
something that we're going to be
referencing to at the end of this video
when we go out and buy a standard
40-foot shipping container we can buy
them anywhere from 5 000 to 8 000 on
facebook marketplace so you can pick up
a good quality shipping container for 8k
straight away this sounds phenomenal we
are saving so much money but remember
you have a tin shed that has absolutely
nothing in it so let's break down the
bare bone minimums of what you need to
pay for before you can actually use
anything inside this space so if we
break down all of our ceilings and our
walls and our insulation plasterboard
and painting we're going to actually
spend quite a bit of money it's going to
cost us 440 for our ceiling insulation
almost 1100 for our wall installation 2
200 for our suspended ceiling and
plasterboard another 2
300 for our wall plaster board 1000
bucks for our painting our timber
laminated floor is going to be another
eleven hundred dollars and our tiles for
maybe the small bathroom that we have is
another 560
all these prices i have brought in from
the rollinson's construction guide which
is a quantity surveyor's database of
up-to-date pricing again in this world
this changes continuously but these
prices are relatively accurate for what
we can actually assume to be paying for
the bare bone minimums finished and
installed now we also obviously need
some windows some doors power points
some light switches and some actual
lights that's going to cost us a little
bit more money too so let's assume we
have 20 of our wall area as glazing
which is quite conservative that's gonna
cost us four thousand one hundred
dollars a couple doors one internal
three external is gonna cost us 300 and
500 respectively so 835.50
for those doors
let's assume 10 gpos
at 100 each there's a thousand dollars
five light switches and lights we're
talking about 650
and then we want to break down some of
our actual plumbing requirements our
toilets our kitchen sinks our trots
we're spending another 700 for the
vanity 285 for the toilet almost 2 000
for our shower 1100 for our kitchen sink
and thirteen hundred dollars
for our trough now these prices are just
understanding the bare costs i haven't
included anything like cabinetry or
handles so we're not even finished with
our internal fit out of our shipping
container so already we've spent a grand
total of 28
528
this shipping container home is nowhere
near finished and yet we've spent more
than it would cost you to build the
cheapest home you can actually build so
why on earth are we going ahead and
wasting all our money and time in
shipping container homes
when we can actually build something
that is high quality to the standard a
livable place for significantly less
anyway that's all from me my name is
david thomas if you enjoyed this video
make sure you check out the rest of my
videos in the playlist to the side of me
if you love this video make sure you
smash that subscribe button down below
and like always i'll see you next monday